on the bound for the san diego padres is
chris paddock 25 year old making his
fourth start coming off his first
winning decision that was back in
pittsburgh
he had a career-high 99 pitches as i
mentioned his fourth start and opponent
hitting 250. you know one thing i'm
going to look for tonight is the swings
and misses on breaking balls boundaries
are going to bounce back tonight after
last night and first pitch ball game
grounded back up the middle ranging to
the backhand is profile the throw is
going to get there
nicely done by church and profar to
start the night nice range right out of
the gate for jerks and profar at the
keystone tonight this is not an easy
play
and he utilizes the bounce on purpose so
one out here in the first inning brings
up daniel vogel back
pogoback strikes out first k of the
night for chris paddock hence the great
late movement down and away to dynamo
dynamo goes down swinging two down in
the first inning official garcia
standing in
swing and a miss and paddock with
back-to-back caves uh one two three
first inning padres are coming up
corbin's not leading the league in just
about everything he's in the top five
in just about every major category on
the mound
fourth appearance
a point 49er in run average and check it
out no walk 30 punch outs
picked up a win his last timeout against
the cubs facing his former teammate
trent grisham two walls two strikes to
grisham and he goes down swinging
corbin blows it right by him so no walks
31 punch-outs for corbin
has worked wonderfully for him and a
breaking ball he's swung on and missed
will secure the strikeout so a couple of
punch outs for burns to start his night
and we are through one in san diego
travis shaw stands in
the fly ball to center sending grisham
back all the way to the track he leaps
and makes the catch
trent grisham the former brewer robs a
current brewer in travis shaw
time to leap and reels it in hitting it
to the wrong guy
there's gold in that glove here's will
meyer
2-2 pitch got him strikeout number three
of the first five that burns has retired
and he is now
too short of tying adam wainwright
paddock and burns have retired all six
they have faced so far 2-2 pitch
let's hit in the air in the right center
field he hit it well and it's gone
second home run and as many nights for
billy mckinney and the brewers jump out
to a one-nothing lead that's just a nice
short stroke maddie waited back nicely
and knocked it out of here always
looking to add more here in the third
ready with the payoff to garcia and he
missed upstairs with a fastball and they
are loaded for the cleanup man with
paddock as travis shaw who leads this
team in rbis
and shaw rips one down the line and that
is a fair bowl
burns is in
coming in is the big man vogel back in a
two-run double for shaw
and it's three-nothing brewers my
goodness how quick were those hands you
see that swing
[Applause]
steps to the plate and he sends one into
left field to base it garcia's in here
comes shaw throw to the parade and not
in time shaw he's in
and it's a five-run inning for the crew
five runs with two outs
corbin burns has retired the first six
he's faced here's the one-two
and that time he did bite on the slider
and that strikeout number four for burns
one away
one away here in the third luis caposano
here comes the one two
make it 35 strikeouts in no walks two up
two down burns with his fifth strikeout
now he's tied wainwright for the most
strikeouts to start a season for a
starting pitcher without issuing a walk
two outs bases empty for chris paddock
and it's a called third strike
cutter at 96 up and in and 36 strikeouts
to start this season for corbin burns
without issuing a walk the most since
1893 for a starting pitcher
one out one on
jake cronin worth the hitter here's the
one-two
and that is strike three call strikeout
number seven for burns two men out
now facing hosmer
pitch is profile bluffs as though he'll
steal little chopper charging robertson
and not in time hosmer
beats the throw as profile will motor to
third
they're at the corners for will myers
lays out and makes a spectacular catch
my goodness what a play
by billy mckinney to keep the padres off
the board
loaded with one away here in the fifth
head to grisham one and two here it
comes
did he hold up
big strikeout for burns that's nine
tonight
and now he'll deal with jericho profile
doesn't matter didn't get shark out
number 10 he gets a harmless ground ball
to kesten hero as burns turns back the
threat
two and two to will myers
and that is strikeout number ten
for corbin burns two down vogelback at
first base and abaciel garcia
fly ball to left sending fam back
at the wall to make the catch
garcia just flipped the bat and got all
the way to the wall
first off that bench is fernando tatis
jr
on the ground and through into left
field a base hit for tatis
up to second base goes kim
two on two down now for the padres in
the seventh nando in the pinch
burger trying to make it harmless in the
1-2 and that is strike three call
he gets the outside edge couple of
strikeouts
in the eight from brad boxberger
and we move to the ninth
in san diego
different than his past roles with the
san diego padres
swinging a miss and he strikes out
robertson to open up the ninth inning
break up the a's yeah ten in a row
with a fly ball hit back at a deep
center field grisham going back and
that's gone
jase peterson dead center
sends one out of here and it's six to
nothing
two outs
nobody on two and two to luis caposano
here it comes game over
burns the corner
and drew rasmussen
sets him down in order as the brewers
have taken the first two games of this
series